[Music]
I think what we have here in Hollywood
is high Arts
it's funny
[Applause]
anywhere in the whole world where would
you go
I always wanted to be part of something
bigger yes let's go
something that lasts that means
something
[Music]
you know when I first moved yeah
you know what the Shines on all the
doors read no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that good morning good job for
you I'll do anything that's the
[ __ ] they said to screw us
[Applause]
this [ __ ] is stealing the scene right
from under me she's icing her nipples so
they perk up through her dress I ain't
ice in my nipples this is natural
what do you say we come in for my
close-up now
what are your thoughts for the future
shouldn't stand in the way of progress
twist
the girl seems nice she is she has no
idea what's next there's
a building now people care about Morris
I've never done nothing that disappoint
people my whole life but I made it on my
terms not theirs
[Music]
we are going to be more than they ever
bargain for
foreign
[Music]
and I'm going to bed
[Music]